[Music]
one of homies
how you livin how you doing LEF koe man
and I got in burr back in this seat can
I spell my name
ing BER man I'm a player no no no I
haven't heard that yet I don't know if
straight you're definitely
everybody loved you last week oh I
appreciate that yeah some really nice
dm's that were sent your way I had to
for I forwarded them on to hang verso if
you wrote nice things about him I
forwarded them on I really appreciated
that great things about you and then the
outreach after the Nate Burleson episode
oh my god yeah I am getting five to ten
a day
Nate texted me this morning and said bro
this is overwhelming to the point where
Nate has already told me he wants to
come back soon he already knows what he
wants to talk about and I'm just saying
that that's the reason the 33 percent is
amazing
because when we have somebody on and he
says something and it connects with you
guys and then you reach out to them and
go thank you so much they reach out to
me and go when do I get to come on again
so Nate might be a recurring guest at
some point like a monthly thing or
whatever but just know that you have had
an impact on him so if he's had an
impact on you you've had an impact on
him we're gonna do a few things today
coming up a little bit later interview
with spice Adams
the former Chicago Bear his actual name
is anthony Adams Kyle spice i think
spices despite it's too good of a
nickname he walks into her me like that
that spice adams we go into the
character cream Biggums that basketball
character you've seen his laugh haha i
can't do it as well as him and a number
of other things so stay tuned for that
but we have a number of things to get to
including whoa big offseason but first
my list we i ranked Thursday night on
Twitter the NFL quarterback starting
Hunger Games rankings from 1 to 32 if
you're watching on YouTube I will put
the link to the tweet below a my ranking
so you guys can argue there but also hit
me up on social but
I'm gonna present my top five my bottom
five and then of course in burr is gonna
go through and figure out where I'm an
idiot but also where I was right
overall feelings about the list before I
get into it more or less accurate than
the beer-chugging list yeah well we know
the entire point of putting up these
lists is just to make people angry and
make people incensed that you're wrong
about this thing we'll never be able to
prove math right and and so that's if it
was a perfect list if I saw it and I had
no comments there would be a problem
with the entire paradigm so yes
there I have a lot of problems with you
that's what makes it a gorgeous list so
the list again is how would the starting
NFL quarterbacks finish if we were to
put them into a Hunger Games yeah and
this is gonna be a recurring thing right
here so keep those ideas coming because
people were writing really funny things
like who's most likely to take your
shirt off at a baseball game we're just
we're gonna go through a bunch of them
right there's a lot of weeks in the year
let's just make a lot of rankings and I
think the funny way too is when you
reverse engineer a list like you were
saying like what's a list where Dwayne
Haskins would be number one it's funny
to go geez how can I think of a list in
which tween Haskins is number one that's
when you're in like week 22 of this
thing and we're like God why did we
commit to doing this every single week
and we're like okay who hasn't been
first yet let's try to reverse
engineering right yeah yeah I think
it'll be a lot of fun so my top five for
who will finish at the top of the Hunger
Games for quarterbacks number one I did
Carson Wentz I'm gonna give the five and
I'll explain number two dak Prescott
number three Aaron Rodgers number four
Andrew Luck number five Patrick mahomes
all of these guys are athletic all of
these guys can get on the move Carson
Wentz is my number one because he
actually hunts this is a man that can
actually scent like like follows scent
and do tracing and he's taken a life of
an animal before dak I think surprised a
lot of people at number two he is also
someone that is outdoorsmen
he is always fishing he is hunting he is
from the south this is a guy that's
always out there and I just see him as a
hunter and his name in Dakota
is his name right like there's something
about like if when your name is Denver
your name is Dakota it's just you feel
country it feels like you you're a guy
that's experienced nature but that's a
great point yeah in fact of that Aaron
Rodgers is one that caught a lot of
people off-guard and my reasoning for
putting him at number three was he's not
afraid of being the lone wolf because
he's been that way through his entire
life and with this football team that he
doesn't need alliances but I still think
I'll have enough support from the
outside factor sending him gifts and
stuff that I also think some of the
younger players will look up to him and
then he will take their lives oh I had
some comments okay that's Andrew Luck I
have him at number four because I feel
like he can read the moss on the sides
of trees and if anyone knows how to be a
survivalist it's him and Patrick mahomes
he can just take lives from any distance
at any spot so why don't we start with
my top five your biggest issues with
that no real real issues I mean those
are all really solid choices I love
Andrew Luck just there's something about
him that that hold that that feeling
that he's this Civil War general right
we've all just decided that he's he's
this real American hero type person that
we've all built up in our minds fresh I
totally buy that as a Hunger Games my
overall thought though is that the
younger guys are gonna be gunning for
the big names that's just I mean I'm
trying to put myself in the action you
think multiband together I think if
there are gonna be alliances that form
Tom Brady is like I don't need the help
of Drew Brees i don't need the help of
Aaron robb you're thinking Tyler might
look at dwayne Haskin that's what I'm
saying go let's do this together exact
Sam dartle and Josh Allen and Lamar
Jackson and Baker Mayfield are like our
league this is our time you know and so
I'm just worried for the older
quarterbacks that might be a step slower
than they're used to and you know how it
is when you enter your 30s or even unto
your 40s you've got the mentality of a
young guy but you don't have the foot
speed that you once did so if these guys
are overestimating some of their
physical traits at this point maybe it's
someone like Dwayne Haskins who comes in
and is like hey no one's even thinking
about me right Dwayne Haskins ran a sub
540 so he doesn't have the speed to make
this argument but I feel like you like
did I put hoot I put too low like Cuyler
ya Kyler's where did I have where do we
have here it's a 29
still I'm a calamari at 10:00 I'm just
saying like some of the young guys might
so so maybe that's not true Biscay was
he can scamper look at that he's a bunny
out there he can and he is at 12 I think
like I put breeze at eight strictly
because I believe he's still physically
there and I believe his strategy could
be better than all of them because I
think also with youth comes ego and with
ego comes putting yourself in vulnerable
positions like I have Cam Newton at
seven and a lot of people thought that
he should have been number one I look at
Cam Newton and I think eventually he's
gonna get too cocky and I think a lot of
guys I put the top or people that can
suppress their egos for the entire game
once you get to the final ten it's a
waiting game
but it's location it's a patience game
right and so that's why I looked at like
the luck like luck will just meditate
himself into getting past 15 of these
guys also luck I read some stat a while
ago obviously we don't think of him as a
running quarterback but apparently when
he goes for the first down he's one of
the most effective and NFL has credible
so it's like a guy that picks his spot
yeah nose had it that's why I love
Andrew Luck in that top five doesn't
necessarily have to be the fastest guy
but the guy that knows oh I can make it
to that Oak Grove yeah you know a 5,000
percent absolutely
my bottom five and then we'll get into
other people that you think were wrong
twenty eighth I had Derek Carr really I
just he I find him to be a religious man
and I don't think that he would ever
pull the trigger I think he'd go this
isn't real
he's dead Dwayne Haskins he's too slow
joe flacco he's too Haskins and Flacco
are both 6-foot like they're both taller
and slow they just don't fit the hunger
games well sure Eli it's just perfect
and Mariota is last and the reason I
have Mariota last is he has no bones in
his body that would allow him to take a
life he's too nice now I probably should
have put him higher because he can
escape death but I just thought I needed
to have someone there that would go guys
there's got to be another way and that's
why I have him last all right you
brought up the religious aspect of car
okay
one big thought this wasn't a huge deal
in the movies but it was a big deal in
the books and I
I sound like one of those guys like none
of the books there was the fact that you
were self-aware there makes it okay
thank you yeah but there was a big thing
in The Hunger Games that you would
receive packages from benefactor yes
right Derek Carr if he's out there and
he's praying there might be like a whole
swath of America that's looking at this
guy and he becomes their their hero
right and they're they're providing him
with gifts they're providing him with
weaponry they're giving him like maps of
the anything the benefactors can really
tip the scales you believe that he could
tap into religious USA I'm saying that
if he's got like an authentic you know
there's a religious people in America
that would see that they'd see him as
their as their you know the the
figurehead of their movement I'm just
saying like that's a great point
possibly some in effect okay okay and as
you know as a Patriots fan I'm perfectly
fine with any eli ranking that puts him
toward the bottom overall though are
there any other rankings of guys at too
high too low in general um i think we've
mentioned this before but anyone that
has kids right anyone that has something
to live for a little extra something you
just you have to give them a 5% bump and
they've got that protectionist they've
got that survivalist right and you know
I'm a dad now and this the an automatic
thing happens when you become a dad that
you're just like no first aid
you just know CPR right you just you
learn things yes like I became really
good at putting a band-aid on or taking
a splinter out it just magically
happened as soon as the baby was born
interested and so after like nine kids
I don't know what Phil Rivers knows it's
possible he like can identify every
plant and knows which berries are edible
and I my so I have Phillip Rivers at 17
I've been one spot behind Brady felt
felt a tad loafer for Phil my thought
about Phil was this completely agree
with your saying that's why I have him
over a lot of guys but I think Phil out
of everyone in The Hunger Games might
enjoy the relaxation of being away from
their family too much so I see him at
one point with his back to a tree going
he might let his guard down because he
doesn't have the nine kids I don't mind
that at all and it's you know in a weird
way being at home with the nine kids
might be harder than the Hunger Games so
I just don't know if the motivations
gonna be there though there's that thing
you know with
The Hunger game starts you have to run
into the middle and grab a sword or grab
a bow and arrow or whatever and he just
grabs like a pool float good he's like
this is nice what an afternoon that's
awesome
all right so the the other thing that
was funny for me was I dropped this list
and then 10 minutes later
Carson Wentz gets a new contract and for
a second I went did the Eagles just see
my list and have seen me put Carson
Wentz the number one quarterback and go
that's the that's the if you're out
there if you work for the Eagles even as
like an intern yeah yeah like a
marketing associate if you're somewhere
in the Eagles or just tweet me a winky
ayah mode oh yeah guys yeah just want
the two eyes is looking at that tweet no
but Carson Wentz just to kind of bring
it to football really quick gets a
monster contract but at the same time a
lot of eagles fans right now are asking
me is this a good move from I'm not
gonna do all the numbers if you haven't
seen what Joe banner said on the Rich
Eisen show I think it's an interesting
note that because the Eagles were so far
under the cap that so much of the
guaranteed money that the Eagles just
gave to Carson Wentz is coming off the
books in the next two years which are
the two years before the extension kicks
in and also while the team right now is
still really good meaning that they may
have four years of like Carson Wentz at
around twenty four million dollars a
year which is like barely in the top ten
and by the time they get there might not
be in the top ten
yeah and so that they get four years of
like a top quarterback if he gets back
to where he was at that level could be
incredible I'm so when that goes all-in
on Carson Wentz for everyone out there
that goes what about his injuries you
cannot bet for or against injuries it's
just not a predictable thing it's it's
it's random but I look at Carson Wentz
and I think he will have an MVP level
caliber season this year never having
won before Falls to go 100% he was I
think probably the B favorite fervor
when he was so two years ago when they
won the Super Bowl he was when he played
last year he was kind of hit and miss
and then foals kind of carry them
through the rest of the way but I
believe whether it's from me here and
that Carson Wentz is completely
changed his diet this offseason it's the
fact that the entire team has come out
and now they're fully supporting him and
there isn't that ooh what about Nick
Foles and he that distraction isn't
there anymore and then also because
there were the stories about you know me
it is a little bit divisive and it
forced Carson to interact with more guys
uh and the introduction of the Shawn
Jackson as an actual deep threat
I think Carson Wentz is about to have a
really really big year and I'm super
excited as the Eagles fan is just a fan
of the sport and I specifically remember
to how well he handled that that pass
off to Knowles because it would have
been so easy for him to just be a little
kind of like sneering on the sidelines
even if the cameras caught him one time
sneering on the sidelines even if it had
nothing to do with football yeah just
reading an annoying text people would
have blown it up as like always not a
leader
oh he's you know he's being a
distraction I feel like he handled it as
well as any person could possibly handle
being in that situation which just spoke
to like he's that the sort of guy that
does that who before me last season
everybody was saying oh they're gonna
make a decision this could tear the team
apart I said you're literally talking
about the two quarterbacks in the NFL
with the least egos Nick Foles and
Carson Wentz whether it's because of
their faith whether it's because of who
they are as people the way they talk
they are genuinely happy for each other
this is not an act I think about a
little bit like Kawhi Leonard right now
sure he goes up there and he gives
answers that if you're a media member
you're like this is awful
like you're giving me nothing but if
he's on your team that's how I want my
guy to think I want my quarterback to be
the Tom Brady where we go no I focus on
every day like it's every day but what
we love is we love the quarterbacks like
Baker may feel that it's like nah
sign your contract and get here it's
your problem but it's it's you want your
quarterback to be boring you want your
quarterback to have boring quotes that's
why my quarterback to be boring I want
everyone else's quarterback to be exact
wrapping the quote like likes content
you look at Bill Belichick as a Patriots
fan and you go yes don't say anything
nobody ever way anything that could help
the other team beat you next week but if
you're a national media member looking
for insight on the next game it's
frustrating
yeah like we love we love the
Hugh Jackson's we love the guys that go
I will I will I'll jump in the lake if I
go zero wins next year and then he's got
to jump in a lake like that's great for
media but we but you really want the guy
that doesn't say [ __ ] and that's what
Carson Wentz is so I'm excited for them
okay so overall the list the only thing
that scared me is the people that
reacted to my list as though they were
my quarterback rankings right you have
dak over Aaron Rodgers I'm like you
don't know how to read Twitter so we
don't know what the next list is but
we're gonna preview it on Wednesday and
I'm gonna want your guys insight so
we'll keep this going right all right
you know what time it is I don't Nick
let them know what time it is
[Applause]
Nico season it's gonna be the one big
offseason we got our top five of the
week but first how many honorable
mentions we have to I couldn't I there's
just so many good ones I couldn't get it
down to just five we have to have a 200
we'll mention now that your now that
you're in it and whoa big offseason is
in your veins are you able to even read
any offseason news stories without
contemplating it that's a good question
it I think that happens no matter what
your job is you start thinking about
that so like my buddy is a civil
engineer so every time he walks into a
restaurant he's looking at the beams
he's looking at the pie shorter he can't
help himself right so if you're thinking
whoa big offseason no matter what I mean
my wife could be like hey you know I
want to go to that restaurant for dinner
I'm like whoa I wonder if that
restaurant had a big offseason you you
just get in that mindset and so yeah I
feel like that should be my full-time
job I can't handle any of the other
responsibilities in my job I just want
to look at was like when I go to Pro
Football Talk or ESPN or the red zone
dot org and I go on there and I see like
coach says about player I'm like oh but
it else it messes with your head cuz
sometimes you'll see legit news stories
it'll be like hey Baker Mayfield been
traded and you're like wait a second
wait no that's that's bad that's not a
well he has not been traded by the way I
was making that up as an example right
so what are they one of the honorable
mentions okay Seahawks Shaquille Drew
Griffin lost 12 pounds this offseason he
gave up wings had a ton of big chicken
his twin brother hired a chef okay
season the chef comes in every other day
to their shared home to drop off
personalized meal Shaquille has cut out
most carbohydrates he's focusing on lean
proteins such as baked chicken and quote
any type of seafood man I love when we
explain diet foods we all know what the
healthy options are oh you're eating
more vegetables and baked and and not
and fish that look we all know that the
news would be if he's like I'm on an all
candy bar yes and I've lost 12 12 bounds
on whopper and I'm all muscle yes that's
what I want weight-loss classic whoa big
offseason but an honorable mention yeah
it's like it's in the mix like yeah
Steelers linebacker Devon Bush okay is
quote turning head oh [ __ ] wait wait a
minute we're not facing the field but
why were they turning the quote from TJ
watt my favorite younger brother in the
league he's quicker than snot he's been
flying around and making a lot of good
plays quicker than snot does not have a
speed yeah if you kind of like if you do
that that wasn't snot thanks I think
that's what he's referring to I it makes
me realize now I wonder what Watts dad
is like like I thought of TJ and JJ and
there's another one it might be DJ a
Derek watt Derek well back out of the
Chargers I wonder what their dad is like
like he just seems like the ultimate dad
joke because those guys all seem to have
like a lot of dad phrases like I feel
like JJ Watts been a dad for years and
he's not a dad but TJ Watt faster than
snot it's great turning heads that feels
like something that a 60 year old
football coach would say right like who
was that Bob Wiley coach yeah Bob Wiley
right
that is some guy that would just be like
you know you're asking about some new
rookie there's faster than snot out yes
it's nut Oh
next question yeah that's what I want
I'll tell you what he started a wipe off
that a brow in the middle of August when
you dig in a ditch in Lake Town
TJ watt is in his mid-20s does he talk
like that when he's like going to his
buddy's bachelor party isn't speaking
like kind of old guy aphorisms no I just
think that the whole watt family carries
around protein shakes wherever they go
yeah just go eat clean bro and
like he's the guy with the thermos
that's always shaking it yes keep the
sentiment from me well if if faster than
snots on the top five I'm very excited
okay this one's so up your alley so this
is number five
yeah this is number five a profile from
the great Jeff leg Wald from espn.com
quote he's well he's talking about all
the fancy cars that he sees at the
Broncos practice then in the front row
most days tucked between the rest there
is a function over form
it's the off-the-rack blue Dodge pickup
truck model year 2000 with the cracked
window and assorted items scattered
across the dashboard he considers the
truck to be what he is reliable sturdy
up to the job and decidedly happily even
under the radar we're talking about
fullback Andy Janovich oh my god that to
me like writing an entire piece I mean
this is like at least a thousand-word
piece on espn.com prominently displayed
on the football section talking about a
foot a fullback that owns a truck and
and we're supposed to glean from this
some information about how good he is
now but I am a hundred percent
guaranteeing that there are Broncos fans
out there that are going I wish we had
some more blue trucks in that parking
lot we needed more grit like Andy
Janovich the full-back come to think of
it you know who had a very similar story
couple years ago people went nuts for it
your man Kawhi Leonard sure right
correct Cousins is like this too
Kirk Cousins has like a minivan with
like 200,000 miles perfect and people
equate that to like how much of a hard
worker they are I know I do that with
Kauai that Kauai still like a 1997
Toyota Corolla or something like that
like it makes the fact that they have a
shitty car makes me like them more do
you have a dream car do you have a like
oh the day after I win the latter I
remember and I've never thought about
this before this is not what I would get
but I remember when I was 13 and I was
walking around with my parents somewhere
and a black pickup truck with tints and
hydraulics went down the street okay and
and I was like that's the car I want and
I don't know why you just channeled that
in a moment I don't I don't really have
a dream car cuz I live in New York so
the fact of like owning a car like it's
not something I ever we New Yorkers beat
I'm gonna play a driver
we have dream apartment yes we don't
have dream cars yeah I walk past and I
go that's the brownstone
exact but I do like I look at cars I go
that's dumb yeah but I love deducing an
NFL player down to the car they drive
like in a weird way
is he taking shots and all the great
cars that are there like are you saying
that von Miller is spoiled and that he's
a diva yeah I mean that's that's like
the extended argument which clearly
doesn't hold any water it's like if
you're gonna make some assumptions about
Andy Janovich and the fact that he
drives a 2000 Dodge does that mean that
everyone that doesn't drive a 2000 Dodge
is not working their ass off of course
it doesn't mean that but it is like it's
kind of like a fun whoa it is also that
it's whoa big offseason the full-back
drives a shitty truck so back is exactly
yeah yeah I do like that he's like
central casting fullback though ready
for number four yes your man Vic Fangio
OH unday I love this one the last day
it's like the last day of summer camp
right we saw like teams going bowling we
saw the Jets were doing at the driving
range and Le'Veon Bell was on Instagram
they can find everybody swing the master
of this by the way spring training
baseball Joe Maddon he like brings
Penguins into the dugout or something
brought a magician in so Vic Fangio is
trying to put his own spin on it he had
a day for hit instead of practice and
this is like a substitute teacher being
like we're just gonna watch a movie
today when that TV wills it [ __ ]
laserdisc so what he did a day that
included a homerun Derby a
remote-control car race which sounds
super fun [ __ ] makes me think of
Ocean's eleven when they find those yes
yes yes a basketball shootout a water
balloon toss a golf chipping contest I'm
sure that got super competitive a dunk
tank which apparently featured John
Elway in the bow and number one he had
shaved ice Italian Shane McMahon Gio
bringing in the Italian shaved ice I got
a guy like if Vic was like I got a guy
named Mario that we're gonna fly in from
Chicago shaved ice you ever had you like
cherry you ain't had it like this you
like mango you are gonna blow your
[ __ ] this is the guy that Paulie
walnuts went to and he's like he's like
oh yeah he's in Hackensack it's worth
the drive I literally just want to make
meatballs with Vic Fangio I know you do
like I just want to be smacking together
it's a half veal half beef blend that my
grandmom use
keep stirring the sauce and I wanted
this thick yeah but the fact I just and
then I also saw some stuff about Vic
Fangio that he wears the same gray sweat
suit every practice D job style Mark
Zuckerberg style that's the new thing
with these executives they have like a
closetful it's like Bart Simpson opening
is good pick Fangio I don't I'm just
fascinated at how much of a classic
football guy he is why it's to me it's
perfect the there are certain
coordinators in this league that never
get a chance and they are just the
coordinator and Vic has been that guy
for so [ __ ] long and the fact that
we're finally getting him to see what
he's like he's observed a lot of head
coaches get hired and fired and he's
such a good DC that he was there before
the coach Chicago like he was there with
John Fox he got fired they kept him on
so he's seen these field days he's seen
Mike Nolan wearing a suit and so the
fact that he's wearing an all gray sweat
suit at all times he I feel as though
Vic it's he's finally coming to his own
it's like the caterpillar turning into a
butterfly like I'm just so obsessed with
Vic Fangio it's a [ __ ] problem
I love because they're gonna refer to
him all year as rookie coach you know
like they do with Nick nurse right now
yeah in the NBA Finals Nick nurse has
been a basketball coach for like 35
years it was his first head coaching job
in the NBA but like Vic Fangio knows his
way around a football locker room he
knows his way around a team he knows
about personnel like this is not a
rookie coach you know what I mean yes
Italian shaved ice it's so good next up
Washington's defensive line is quote
bringing rookie Montes sweat with them
into the weight room dun dun dun whoa
this is great so the defensive linemen
have brought sweat with them to lift
weights or do boxing work in the weight
room quote it's a small gesture but one
Jim Tomsula recognizes as a sign of
respect okay so the reason this is
interesting is sweat is an edge slash
outside linebacker and if you think
about Washington the best part of their
team right now is probably the D lie
you got Doron Payne Jonathan Allen a lot
of big first-round draft picks the last
two years and that was the one area that
was great but the fact that it's Jim
Tomsula who is the like he's like Vic
Fangio like times 2 in terms of like
energy he's a human dodge truck from the
year 2000 that's why he's the MPP the
personal embodiment of sometimes when he
opens his mouth horns like car horns
just come out yeah it's a very effective
coaching technique though but the fact
that he's like listen Rd line is
bringing in the rookie he's adjusting
well it's like a guard being like it's
okay he's found the crew I love that uh
sometimes with these I fall I fall into
the trap right even though we're hunting
whoa big offseason that's you knowing
that it's like not a big deal at all we
need we need to come up with a term for
that I leave it to Twitter but like who
are the people that really buy into
every whoa big offseason because I'll
turn into that once in a while but we
need to come up with like who are the
people that know this is for well the
thing is too is it's the reason I like
to make fun of the woes is you rarely
get stories about Montez sweat not being
invited like you're never gonna hear the
coach go look I'm a little bit worried
about Montez sweat he kind of lunched by
himself recently I think that would be a
whoa in a negative sense that's the real
whoa but you never we never get those
right we never hear he's not adjusting
well we only hear the team loves them
the only one I've seen is I saw a story
recently about Ryan Finley the kid from
North Carolina State for the Bengals
like the reporters are being like oh
he's been awful like he can't make any
throws in camp then I'm like oh that's
not good
but you never hear like all I hear is
you know insert fourth string tight end
as blowing people's faces off see what
what makes me laugh too is the idea that
like some guy happens to be eating lunch
by himself one day because you know he
had to make a phone call right he just
grabbed his tray and walked over there
and then some reporter snaps a photo of
and what does this mean for the team and
oh there's no unity on the D line or
whatever if there was a picture of Kyler
Murray sitting on the bench by himself
and everybody on the other side of the
bench people would turn that into a
thing Colin Cowherd would break it down
for an hour and a half yeah he'd have
the big board up he'd be circling stuff
same reason that when I
when I looked at the first video that's
come out of Cleveland Browns training
camp and remember this is the team
putting this out and twice there's one
clip of Odell talking to Baker and then
also in there there's a clip of him
walking with Freddie kitchens that's
done on purpose like there are probably
times were Odell standing by himself not
talking to anybody no I don't accept but
the sight of them but the sight of them
together it's all like propaganda right
you can always control the narrative but
I'm just it's it's funny how we cling to
these things oh my god but but we are
like we're football fans dying for stuff
in mid-june oh well we're just we're we
were the dog at the bottom of a dinner
table wait top two O's yeah well that's
three have been really good okay this is
this actually made me laugh okay Larry
Fitzgerald says Kyler Murray knows the
offense better than anyone already this
is very real
well 16-year man right Fitzgerald
talking about rookie Kyler Murray
obviously colors the quarterback and
runs some expectations of him and it's a
new system Kliff Kingsbury it's a system
that he kind of knows I'm just wondering
like is this saying that Kyler Murray is
a savant is it saying that it's an
exceptionally easy system is it saying
like maybe there's only like four plays
and Kyler got them two days in advance
you know that's what he knows about it
it also makes me worried that apparently
no one on the offense knows the office
right I don't know if this is gonna feel
really slow start to the season for the
Arizona Cardinals but that's Larry
Fitzgerald endorsing the rookie
quarterback that's what this is that is
so important yeah because there I don't
think there's anyone in this league
respected more by the media than Larry
whether it's because his dad was a
reporter he he like literally interacts
with the media more than any other
player but him sort of knighting the
young guy and saying he's got it when a
lot was made about Kyler's personality a
lot was made about is Kyler smart enough
as we do with a lot of minority
quarterbacks but the fact that he's come
out and said that which is probably a
reach but it also lends to the whole
notion in burr about we wanted to give
Kings Barry his guy it wasn't just about
Kyler it was about
is Barry having an offense and he wanted
his piece to run it right and if this is
true that Kyler Murray knows this
offense inside and out already
that's a whoa that's not a whoa that
that could be a super whoa because his
ability to get out there on the field
quicker see I'm feeding into this right
you're letting you go just go go nuts
this sounds like it's for you it's just
I have to always remind myself that it's
all [ __ ] like it's all of it is
[ __ ] what's Larry Fitzgerald
supposed to say like actually no I'm a
veteran so I know the PlayBook a lot
better than our starting quarterback or
I presumptive starting quarterback like
no of course he's not gonna say that
that's the the part of this that people
don't think about from the media is what
was the question if the question is how
skyler doing and then larry unprompted
said right he actually knows about the
rest of us but if the if the the
reporter goes you know compared and it's
a new offense and everyone's learning
like how's he doing compared to you like
you and i holiness crumbs right I have
led someone into a sound bite right that
churned I went to Avery Williamson who's
now on the Jets when he was on Kentucky
and they're playing Teddy Bridgewater in
Louisville and I asked him this question
Avery if Teddy Bridgewater was running
through the middle untouched and he
didn't slide what would you do and he
said I'd knock his head off but other
people the scrum took I would knock
Teddy Bridgewater's head off and it blew
up and I sat there and was like you need
to include my question he did not say
that unprompted
and we also know like sometimes these
guys it's at the end of a four hour
workout this is the 87th time they've
been asked about the same thing Larry
Fitzgerald's been asked about Kyler
Murray I'm sure 2000 times in the last
month right and I'm sure someone was
like hey can you talk about the
preparation that Kyler Murray has been
bringing right they they put it in that
sort of general phraseology yes and
what's Larry Fitzgerald sposed to say
know you'll be like Colin Murray's he's
awesome he knows the playbook really
well he knows it better than anyone it
might have been something that simple
but we're gonna we're gonna woah if I it
I would put a dollar which is a lot of
money yeah that someone said is Kyler
struggling picking up the place leaning
it in a negative
direction was caught which caused Larry
to push it in a positive either way if
Larry is telling the truth then I'm very
excited for the Arizona Cardinals right
or maybe the question was hey can you
read the words that I wrote next card
and the next guy said we really want to
get our big alright so if that's number
two its number one okay this one I'm
calling this the hammer the number one
woe of the week is the hammer the
Ingeborg hammer nice we need a drop for
that so this this is a two-part whoa
okay because the headline is super well
right
the headline is Daniel Jones is quote a
blend of Eli and Peyton Manning
according to Sean O'Hara that's a real
whoa right they did see this one now I
know we I immediately thought we have
our two thoughts about Eli Manning right
he's a two-time Super Bowl winner but
I'm not her what'd you say he's gonna
make the Hall of Fame he finished with
60,000 yards passing etc Peyton Manning
possibly the only person I would
consider the greatest quarterback of all
time if not Brady right he's definitely
in the top five
yes if you want to go yes oh you're Joe
Montana Dan Marino whatever but Peyton
Manning had a long-ass career doing some
incredible stuff Eli Manning iron man of
the NFL won two Super Bowls Daniel Jones
has not done anything yet and we're
already saying he's a blend of these two
Titans of the game okay what's the
second part so the second part is I did
digging in the actual story cuz the the
headline is what the headline is went
went crazy right I read that quote
telling me it's worse in the body the
quote from O'Hara via S&Y
if you put Peyton Manning and Eli
Manning in a blender Jones is what you'd
get that's not to say that he's a blend
of them he's saying that if you put the
two of those guys in a blender they
would turn into an actually right it's
actually an insult right daniel Jones is
he's the muscles and bones
he is the tendons and ligaments all
splashed up like to make me that's like
a Rick and Morty episode you know it's
like or it's like a bad Aladdin genie
wish were you like I want to be a blend
and it's like we're like family guy I
wish I had no bones and you're this
horrifying human slash you know mosquito
put them into a blender which is not
what he meant
at all but do you think it's a pulsate
or is it a smooth blend yeah it's
it's the new crushed ice how do we get
sponsored by nutribullet yes the
quarterback blend of the week
Wow well the thing is - and I will say
this I have talked to people that have
been to Giants training camp and a lot
of them have said like like our guy deal
I talked to deal and deal said he's
actually been pleasantly surprised with
how he's loved sure than saying that
number one story that everyone has told
me is he's a lot more athletic than they
thought and they're seeing him a lot of
a lot of read-option with with say Quan
which is exciting people because if you
think say Quan did amazing last year
with eight guys in the box and everybody
knew that Eli Manning couldn't throw it
further than 15 yards if you have a
quarterback that can run and if he does
that that that read option and can hold
the backside for one more second the
michael vick LeSean McCoy if you give se
Quan Barclay even a second more of so of
open space that's exciting but to say
that he has a blend of one of the three
greatest quarterbacks of all time and
then a New York Giants legend that has
won two Super Bowls one I did it did it
did it say why like did he see like was
there any physical acts that he saw that
was like there were passes or the way he
leads what's funny so I mean it did say
in the article it said physically the
two are nearly identical Manning stands
at 65 220 Jones is 6 5 to 21 when he
[ __ ] 6 5 frosted cleverly 20 right
and then they also hold their build
similarly and as we found out during
organized team activities they even
offer up the same facial expressions
people went crazy for that photo because
they dad that's where that Manning face
and yeah right and it's a fun tweet but
we're talking about like actual
preparation for the NFL season I don't
know if a facial expression is gonna
tell you what I just realized something
I for here on out will no longer be
[ __ ] on Daniel Jones for two reasons
one this is gonna be a very rough off
season for Giants fans and I don't want
to lean too hard into my Eagles fandom
and alienate them they've lost Odell
Beckham he's gonna be celebrated for the
next few months and we don't if Daniel
Jones doesn't work out I do feel bad for
them but the other reason is I want an
insurance policy in case
Daniel Jones is actually good right so
I'm going to stop and I'm gonna wait to
judge him in training camps and stuff
but I'm sure as [ __ ] not believing that
he's a he's the next Manning Peyton
Manning and Eli man so you're just gonna
be you're gonna be on Daniel Jones
Island I'd like to be on Josh Allen
Island I believe he's gonna be a
top-five quarterback in the next three
years for the Buffalo Bills yeah um I'm
all top five I know it's it's a lofty
I'm just hopeful I think Josh Allen's
gonna have an incredible year I love
Josh Allen I love just those electric
runs like so you take daniel Jones I'll
take Josh I love oh no no I'm not
rooting for Daniel Jones and I am NOT
playing okay do not put that on me
I'm pretty sure that Adam left go Giants
I think to what you're saying though
about Josh Allen if I was gonna agree
with you and join you in that island the
other reason is I feel like he's on the
team that will manage expectations for
him the most with Sean McDermott they're
trying to win 13 to 10 so Josh Allen
only has to be great
for moments to get the 1 or 2 touchdowns
to try and win and I feel like he has
the makeup to be incredible in moments I
don't know if he's gonna throw for 400
yards and be incredibly accurate and
throw 3 touchdowns and no interceptions
but when you need a [ __ ] big play
he's the guy that can break everything
down yeah I love Josh if he can go 10
and 6 and get a wild card like that's a
really nice season for them all right so
you're team Josh I super team Josh Allen
you have plenty of time to think about
it months all right it's time for spice
atoms from impersonations of Ray Lewis
to breaking down Aaron Donald's body to
explaining how he became one of the
biggest meme makers in the world I hope
you enjoy it and just like we saw with
Nate Burleson get into spice Adams
mentions whether it's Twitter whether
it's Instagram let him know how great he
was and how he's part of the 33% because
maybe he'll start making memes with us
hmm anything is possible
always a pleasure thanks for having
homies enjoy yourself we will see a
little bit later this week Ingmar may
have helped us get a really nice guess
but I'm not jinxing it now so in the
meantime enjoy this conversation with
spice Adams
[Music]
okay feels good right yeah The Voice you
hear you may know them as Ironman you
may know him as the griller fat wonder
coach dun dun monarch Mike 8-ball Jamie
every uncle you've ever had every old
head at the spot you may know him as
creamy Biggums he is the 2013 grand
champion of the Dancing with Chicago
celebrities spiced [ __ ] Adams happy to
have you here man hey man thanks for
coming in no problem dude yeah I'm just
chilling man you know just died in my
eyes crossing all my T's trying to put
some paint where it ain't and I see this
shirt yeah I'm gonna be honest I did not
notice it until right now
got some merch coming out there it says
ahahaha
everybody like the laughs man are you at
a point now where people just come up to
you on the street and they want the
laughs that's it really yeah I don't
know I get on Instagram live that's all
everybody right saying it do it I've
become the laughs man I I don't know man
you're a lot of stuff right now like
crazy kinda means it's goin crazy man I
see like I remember when when cream
Biggums and if you don't know its spice
Adams in very short shorts with rexspecs
showing his dexterity all over the place
that had like a wave where it was like
all over the place yeah all of your cat
like the uncle wave right now I still
think is strong but the would you say
that's the biggest it ever got like
that's a meme meme yeah it's you know
what that that video is so old I think
my son my son is 11 now I just saw a
video on your Instagram of him walking
into what looks like high school yeah
yeah and then I and then I thought about
the video I'm like that's another person
yeah I think he was probably like 8 when
that video came out Wow yeah it just
came from the barbershop yeah me and my
son Scott faded then I did cuz he
started a band I'm like
nobody dabs anymore like why are you
doing this so we that was a genuine
reaction yeah you weren't I thought all
along that he was in on it and then he
dad oh he thought he was cool and I'm
like this is the time where you know the
dad is actually cooler than the Sun I
would say in most households kids
understand going viral and memes a lot
more than their parents so to be in a
household where dad is viral and makes
memes hmm what's that dynamic he's
always asking me questions on how to
like edit different videos and stuff
like that cuz he got iMovie on his iPad
and stuff like this so it's a little
different man but I think I think he
understands that you know after football
dad does videos and stuff now so you
know I think that's a pretty cool
dynamic I think it's awesome it's like I
got my second career now cuz when I was
done I was like I don't know what to do
the name of your production company is
legitimately called
no plan production so planned for Dom
but I think that we all could have seen
that this was the future by your
retirement video go on youtube check out
spice Adams retirement video I just
watched it where you go to an empty
White Castle and you fill out like a job
application form and that was that was
back when like dead spins gonna be like
check out this football player that
retired in a different way like your
that should have been the signal to
everybody that you were gonna figure
this out yeah man
and that actually me sign an application
that was my wife's idea man so my wife
is getting into it too man and now she's
like oh yeah we should do it from this
angle whatever like let's let's do this
let's do that over whatever so it's like
a full-fledged production you know my
wife get involved now man which is cool
but like I had no plan on what I was
gonna do I created a video and I caused
some old teammates and I was like man
should I put this video out and I yeah
you know we we see you in a locker room
all the time but nobody else really gets
a chance to see so you
is a locker room is hollow ground yeah
man people fans don't realize coaches
don't go into the locker room we're not
not in our locker room didn't I don't
know what they do now I have not talked
to a single player that I've ever said
coaches were allowed in the locker room
it's a no-fly zone if a coach stepped
foot in it if lights will flicker yes I
was in charge of the siren so I'd be a
that came from his mouth bother somebody
flickering the lights and stuff like
that people be banging on tables locker
everything people will be knocking over
all the little laundry bins and stuff
like that it would be a spectacle
because a lot like you're sitting there
and there's like your d-line coach
leaning up against the walls like so the
key is you gotta hit the me gap no we
talked about that outside exactly like
on the field or whatever I think they
know it like that's like our sanctuary
that's like our safe place where is a
chance for us to just be around each
other
played for a good amount of time time
with the San Francisco 49ers time with
the Chicago Bears and I I know that
you're on your second life but I went
back and I looked at every single
quarterback you got in your hand a half
sacks and I will say it's a [ __ ] hell
of a list so I'm gonna say a
quarterbacks name yeah and if it reminds
you of the time you sacked Michael Vick
I don't know how to happen I saw that
and I was like he was with Philly though
right yes okay so it's a little bit
slower you I couldn't SEC the Vig from
the Falcons in fact Michael Vick you
sacked Tom Brady I remember well that
was easy
because peppers just straight up and I
elated the whole right side of the line
so he had so it was just Tom Brady
looking at me like okay I guess I'm a
good sack this so it was it was just me
and Brady like that was it cuz pep just
totally wiped out the whole line did you
have a sack dance like now that I see
all of your your abilities in front of a
camera and dancing and all this being as
though I play for the Niners for four
years yes we went
seven and nine two and fourteen four and
twelve seven and nine again I've tied
rarely had any sex because there's
nothing to celebrate
yeah about when you're losing I think
we're not the greatest sack dance is
ever I would get a penalty man you
celebration you sacked Eli Manning I
remember that that's the game I tore my
my tricep oh he has a little scar and
damn toward my tricep I guess that's
kind of great it was in December I
didn't even know I play tore it in the
first quarter and I played the rest of
the game with a toy what a torn tries to
damn kids can't complain about anything
no I'm an painter if I tell my son man
you know I play football so you don't
have to you sacked Donovan McNabb on
three different occasions it's your most
sacked quarterback I like plan Philly
you [ __ ] yeah you sacked Donovan
every time and Vic all them on the
Eagles hey man I appreciate Philly man
how many Philly was good to me he sacked
David Gerard Rex Grossman who you
eventually were teammates with later
Brad Johnson Seneca Wallace Kyle Boller
Gus Ferran and my former co-host Chris
Simms yeah yeah Chris man Chris tough
man yeah Chris play with like a ruptured
spleen or something like bloated Oh
Chris Jenkins and Thomas Davis sandwich
he almost died that sound bad
yeah but when I was looking for Ross my
first set your guts right was your first
set first sec man that had to feel
incredible did a little spin move whoo
we still lost I didn't do a sack dance
then either cuz I mean we were down God
so you had respect for the game like
that oh yeah isn't that gonna be you
know dancing about and you're losing my
fire touchdown man
this back when moss were lined up and
just put his hand up like he already
knew I mean I've never heard a cannon so
many times because that's what they do
when Minnesota
scores like that cannon off boom it was
like I heard that every time
yeah boom how many time we go here it is
so it was really something when he when
he was in his prime it was unlike
anything else that was in the NFL
Burning Man was a walk in touch now yeah
walk in touch now and then you can do
about it like you can play awesome
you compressive and ain't gonna matter
is even is later go get open dude I was
talking to Bart Scott and I said man
you're a [ __ ] talker out you don't take
trash from anybody was there anybody
that in Tamar are you from Detroit as
well another good Detroit guy we came
out the same same year mattis he went to
southeastern exactly this school is like
their southeastern jungle ears like what
is a jungle ear that sounds like
something I wouldn't want to say man
yeah Bart that's that's my home you
don't is it man he's a man but he was
telling me that the one dude that he
never wanted to [ __ ] with was Larry
Allen he said dude that could bench 500
from Compton I'm just curious was there
a dude that you went up against you're
like toughest [ __ ] ever yeah
definitely I would have to agree with
him really and I caught Larry Allen
during the tail into his career when he
came to the Niners so I had to practice
every day against Larry so it always
came time where we will run this drill
which a lot of players in college
murmuring I don't know why we were doing
it in the pros because you know we had
samurai Mike their co-chair is Lord has
told me about hey listen we don't do
this drill I mean I mean he was like so
intense man
and we would be in in meetings cuz he
used to coach the linebackers so he
would come in on nine on seven nine or
seven as where as nine offensive people
with seven defensive people or whatever
it's like it's the like meat and
potatoes of your defense and he would
come in there and we would watch the
linebacker do like this just one step we
wanted coach rewinded coach rewind that
for me again I mean we will watch one
play
for like ten minutes and it will all be
like that you have like 90 plays
together yes
so he'll acts the answer to every
question that he acts is get lower so
he'll say what do you think you need to
do on this play we had we had a
linebacker his name was Brandon more
okay hey Brandon what are you posed to
do on this play and Brandon say well I
guess I could have recognized the screen
yeah you could've did that but what else
I guess I could have you know attacked
the guard with my hands and use my hands
and got him off me
yeah but what else could you did get
lower that was the answer for everything
so did you guys just start saying it
whenever he'd ask a class we would say
it like not in front of him but like in
the locker room why nobody was around
kind of like debo yeah yeah yeah here
come debo yeah I'll be talking again
when he leave but the answer to
everything was getting lower what does
your daughter's play get lower lower
that's it that's all he talked about was
being low he thinks he think like you're
posed to be like down on the ground in
your stance and you're supposed to be
able to sprint in that stance as well I
don't like army crawl through the
Auckland never do it right Bart told a
story about when Singletary got to the
Ravens and the art and aliased Thomas
and Ray had already been there for three
years and it's like what are you gonna
teach us but like we know Rex's defense
better than anybody and he said that
Singletary was the worst X's and O's
coach that he's ever been around he just
didn't know what L he was talking about
and what I realize is when Singletary
gave that speech I want winners yeah the
the point the public loved it hmm but
I'm now realizing that the players were
like what the [ __ ] have we just signed
up number one we don't put you in the
mouth
and number two we must execute and
number C we will remain lower average
real everywhere we go we gonna be lower
like that's that's him all day man man
he
coach Nolan Mike Nolan was our head
coach shooting time and so co-signatory
was the assistant head coach whatever so
Wednesdays
coach Nolan would talk to us and then
Thursday turn it over to single singer
Terry would talk to us and also he led
Bible study classes - so it's like he'd
be chewing you out on the field but then
like you go to couples Bible study with
him - and you know you had like
marshmallows or treats and stuff
whatever whatever it was like dr. Jekyll
mr. Hyde there it was it was hilarious
dude he's got those eyes look we need
you to run faster but we need you to be
lower and there comes Saturday Hey
praise God
you know Philippians 4:13 states I can
do all things through Christ who
strengthens me brother and I know you
can do all things you know I was gonna
say you know what Christ did really will
I love Kousaka Terry man man love man
I'll follow his wife on Instagram and
they got nine kids stop
they got Nikes yeah that takes patience
nine kids I think coach secretary was
like 1 to 10 so now that I hear that
coach done done is that Singletary no no
he just got like you know the same type
of voice or whatever I guess I make
everybody sound like coach Singletary or
Ray Lewis
well I'm oh you have a good Ray Lewis
impersonation so I used to do this thing
on Instagram where I would do I would do
rap lyrics but I would do them as Ray
Lewis I don't know don't ask man no I
creativity comes in funny ways so I
think I did a like a Outkast one that
did pretty well on Instagram where I
think it's Andre 3000 verse I just got a
call from of the way when I just came
from somebody had said something
said Amen you remember me from school no
not really
but he kept smiling like a clown facial
expression looking silly and he kept
asking me what kind of car do you drive
I know you paid stuff like that that's
one of the best rate Louis and person I
knew it takes something so simple and
just momentum is real the way you play
will determine the way that you continue
to play yo sickness I loved it yeah you
gonna use close up instead of sensor
night since it on its tested from victus
everywhere close up is the thing of past
don't nobody use close up no more
brother like he was trying to brush my
teeth right did you ever I'm sweating
him so excited have you done your
impersonation to Ray has he seen his
semen and his reaction at the Super Bowl
in Minnesota and as soon as he as soon
as we made eye contact he said that's
your funny oh that's good funny man as
that's really gonna feel so good yeah
dude I mean it's crazy social media the
reach of social media dude when I look
at your posts and I see some of the
people that comment you know like I had
a tweet recently that was liked by Aaron
Rodgers then I was like oh like I
thought about bringing it out and
putting it in the studio
so I'm he's actually pretty cool man who
was who was somebody like who was very
early on a like or a comment that you
got that you went I can't believe this
person saw my stuff okay I'll tell you a
quick story so cream Biggums I almost
never posted it cuz I thought it was
just so stupid I'm like that's why it
was great I'm in my garage I got these
shorts that are hiked up pivot step 360
yeah I'm traveling I'm doing like all of
this stuff and I'm like it's sitting in
my phone it's ready to go and I'm just
like this is stupid
so we were at a track meet again and
like Ball State in Indiana somewhere
something like that so we had to stay
overnight at this place or whatever so
in the playoffs were on so I was like
before I go to bed I was like I'm just
gonna post this since it's the finals
and stuff like that I'm gonna put a
little finals logo on it whatever blah
blah blah so I'll post it then I go to
sleep I wake music underneath of it yeah
yeah where's Kay I'll wake up and my
phone is going crazy so people like yo
Kevin Hart just post it your video wow
I'm not even a comment he posted it on
his page and I'm like Kevin Hart don't
do that
like he posts his stuff on right age
ever picture something like that I'm
like maybe he just commented and you
know maybe you said it so I go to his
page and sure enough my video is on
there I'm like oh snap so then after
that bleacher report puts it up you know
how it goes
it's like posting or whatever so then in
fast-forward
I don't know a year or something like
that Kevin Hart comes to the United
Center I go check him out whatever and I
know some of the plastic cup boys or
whatever like spank or oh that's funny
night yeah yeah like oh those guys are
hilarious so I talked with Nayeem and he
said hey man where you sitting
so I let him know where I'm sitting at
and me and my wife you know we get there
early like we owe hits man so we get
there early listening to mint-condition
got a new album are we just sitting
everyone whatever somebody come tap me
on the shoulder and they give me an
envelope and I'm like yes so I open up
the envelope and it's like VIP backstage
passes to see Kevin Hart whatever and
I'm just like yeah right ahead is my
wife and I'm just like man we gonna get
there there's gonna be like a Kevin Hart
impersonator it's like man watch out
yeah so did I get to thinking I'm like
oh naive asked me where I was sitting
and like you know you can't be on your
phone at that time whatever they take
all your phones away right so I'm just
like I started putting two and two
together like oh he knew where I was
sitting so he knew where to send a
person to send me this envelope yeah so
I'm like sorry so let's say after the
whatever you know wait around or
whatever then you can go to this VIP
lounge thing that they had the United
Center so me and my wife waiting around
whatever then is we're able to go to
this VIP lounge so as I'm walking there
I see 19 like texting when I was in
what's I mean like oh man cool you like
to show whatever blah blah blah cool
so he's like let's go up there so we go
up to the VIP lounge and then I'm
talking to Nayeem about you know he used
to go to temple and he knew one of my
teammates Jason McKee and stuff sure cuz
he went whatever blah blah we were
rapping he was like hey man you know I
don't think Kevin is coming up here man
you know he kind of just chillin my
artists cool man I didn't could to catch
you've done enough like already like I'm
up here they got chicken tenders
pretzels all type of stuff man I'm
talking with mouth yeah I got a turtle
pocket like Napoleon Dynamite and so
we're chillin whatever and then Kevin
Hart's trainer walks in boss yes Ross
walks in he said dude dooda dooda cream
bagels do whatever you did what you say
not Chuck whatever something like yeah
what's up you know who you here with I'm
like I'm here with my wife like man we
got to take you down to come meet Kevin
so I'm like alright cool so me and my
wife follow boss down and then it's like
a line of people is like 35 40 yards of
people whatever we walked past them go
to like this little back room and then
in the back room it's like some people
that I know whatever so we you know
handshakes husband ever are we kicking
or whatever then it's a door that opens
in there and Kevin Hart comes out he's
talking to somebody like as he's walking
and I didn't want to be rude to whoever
I was talking to him be like a me and
I'm about to go how late get my heart
whatever blah blah so I contend the same
point you're like side I stand a little
taller I'm still kicking with in
whatever and then so kept my heart sees
me make eye contact with me he like oh
he like you know what you say not chunk
out with a fluff line he like look man
I'm gonna be right back I'm about to go
do this meet and greet with him that
long line of people you walked in front
of he goes out he said man don't leave
man I'm coming right back whatever so he
goes out does VIP thing come back here
I'm gonna get back in he said oh that's
it for show right on
like oh that right there it kind of just
like let me know like man like people
who are really like watching my videos
when you get the eye contact and that's
the moment when it's like that
recognition and it's like that immediate
and you've been a professional athlete
like there have been people that you've
made I don't even know that I'd played
an NFL it's wild so I'm like yo like
that right there makes me happy because
it's just like it was the content can
stand on its own yeah yeah cuz it's like
you know I've been putting in a work
then like so unit like that's just the
added bonus like if you follow me then
you find out that I play for your
beloved 49ers Oh beloved Chicago Bears
ever so I knew right away because cream
Biggums had to be a defensive lineman I
have always said the defensive lineman
in my mind are the best athletes in any
sport and people think I'm crazy you got
to be to move all that weight it's it's
the only people that could run a sub 540
and around 300 pounds and do a split
like there are defensive linemen that
can do backflips yeah like it's just the
ratio of weight to agility I don't think
as anywhere else it's like you ever see
yeah you ever saw a rhinoceros run like
that's us
like rhinoceros get up yes they they go
probably like 30 miles per hour
something like yeah there's short bursts
short amount of time but they'll get up
there man so we always talk about wide
receivers our cornerbacks I'm like okay
look at Fletcher Cox like look at Erin
Donald like Erin Donald holy crap he's I
was just talking about it man he's like
watching like weird science man I do was
like created on a computer so man it was
like okay 280 pounds quick ab muscles
right like what how are you over 280 and
you got muscles that you train with
people trying to stand I think we're at
a point now where people are getting
used to Erin Donald and I don't think
they're realizing that ABS on the
defensive lineman is not normal his rare
have you ever seen it before he's a he's
a deer bruh
a deer zebra herd a zebra
like you gotta make a month yeah like I
understand it he's rare rare breed dude
and in defensive lineman change games
yeah you know what I mean for sure here
I still think the hardest position to
play is DB DB you may know why one
mistake as a DB that's a touchdown you
know what I'm saying like you make one
mistake at a defensive line or at least
the yeah I Becker can come and clean it
up for you
can I ask you about one year of your
career you know 2010 you won two awards
the adblock courage Awards and the Brian
piccolo award yeah Brian piccolo like is
the Chicago Bears and the ED block
Courage Award it's such a big deal yeah
2010 I mean the way you reacted right
there what was so special about it what
happened why was it such a big year it
was it was a good year man it was you
know we had Coach Marinelli in and he's
like he's like a guru man like he says
I'm a guy I am the why so if you ever
have a question of why like he'll let
you know like if I'm sitting down having
lunch Miran le right now is the
defensive line coach for the Cowboys yes
in a defense coordinator so if I'm
sitting down at lunch and I got a pepper
shaker right here and a salt shaker
right here he'll come and sit down he'll
be like this right here this is a
double-team now we have a guard right
here just sitting and then we have a
sinner right here he knows like
everybody a name number and stuff like
Cory Lindsley they're they're great
matter this is a scat I forget they
whatever yeah and these these are
tattooed linemen that are gonna block
you right there's really this is
double-team right here he's gonna try to
come off on a linebacker how are you
gonna attack that it's like Coach I'm
just trying to eat my Chipotle man he
can't do it like he has to coach like
yeah every single day of his life
man and that live he kind of walks
around with to like he's got that like
former military strut like he's the best
man that's why everybody swears by that
guy he's the best in the world - like no
question it is not even close man but
anyways having him when you have so much
good coach and you you understand the
amount of bag
Genet you had like he breaks down
everything like why you need to get to
the quarterback and and cover 2 versus
cover 3 and I like everything like why
it's important to cover the defensive
end when they take the inside rush just
a bunch of little intricacies that and
this is like seven years into your
career right and you're hearing things
you're like what the hell have I been
here so it was like a breath of fresh
air not saying that you know every coach
that I had was bad but you know
sometimes you only get one year of good
coaching and then they're often like for
instance Dan Quinn remind me so much of
marinelli like he was a great coach and
it was just like I knew he was gonna end
up being a head coach somewhere and you
know the Falcons so you know when you
get good coaching you could recognize it
in 2010 what happened with me how I was
a nominee for the air block Courage
Award was during camp my aunt passed
away and my mom called me at like five
o'clock in the morning 4 o'clock in the
morning I'm like something must have
been like cause you know I'm at camp so
you caught me at 4 o'clock in the
morning my passed away so I talked to
Coach Smith and let him know like hey
you know I passed away whatever I know
we got a game on Saturday his preseason
whatever so we had the funeral on Friday
so on the way to pick up my grandfather
for my aunt's funeral
my grandfather passes away so the next
week we had to do the same thing all
over again so within a 1 and 2 expand we
had two funerals of my eye and then my
gran
so you know I had to we had to away
games to like I had to go to San Diego
for one game yeah yeah so you know the
team knowing that I had to deal with
that they nominated me for the air block
Courage Award and of course the Brian
piccolo award goes to a vet and a rookie
who you know exemplifies everything
great team medical oh dear great yeah
great teammate great sense of humor fun
to be around you know just everything
that embodied a great teammate so for me
to win both of those awards and the type
of year that I had for a franchise yeah
yeah it was great man and it this is the
first time I ever went to the playoffs
and stuff like we were one game away
from the Superbowl we put in Jay get
hurt we put in Todd Collins in the
guitar Collins was 73 years old when he
heard his name called he should have
said coach you know what I can't do it
so this wasn't Caleb Hanie this was Todd
Collins
they put tight Collins in instead of
putting Caleb Hanie in they said put
Caleb Hanie in and maybe we do had a
shot to go to Super Bowl now he threw
the the pick but because the defense was
so [ __ ] good dude Green Bay score
like 45 points against Atlanta in
Atlanta right Aaron Rodgers went off so
we're playing that hot team they scored
on us the first two drives and that was
it the next time they scored was the
intercession that Caleb through and then
green may went to the Superbowl and
racked up a lot of points on the
Steelers we did the same thing yeah if
we'd have beat him but you know I sound
like a oh here who is bitter about a
loser not at all and you know be worse
if you were like you know what was great
I didn't really want to play in the
Super Bowl I had a lot of plans go
around so like actually it was actually
kind of night night you said you said
Aaron Rodgers a cool guy yeah like I
feel like he's like we don't know
anything about him oh really I just like
maybe that's what he wants
yeah maybe he wants to be like
mysterious and stuff like that
you know I'm saying like what guy goes
on Game of Thrones you know I'm saying
yeah only a mysterious guy dude three
pickups on Game of Thrones what if any
credit are that would be epic what do we
do to stop this dragon and then you just
like stuff I'll tell you what to do you
get a jam stay back yeah I guarantee you
don't bite off I feel like as you're
navigating this promotin why are you
gonna orange on your shirt I like you
like interests I don't pick my clothing
will you met you what she does a
wardrobe usually what I usually wear our
sweaters usually have a sweater guy
cardigans what Ernie Johnson is -
bowties I'm trying to be - sweater snot
cardigans funky prints a little bit I
mean I'm not hiking up my daugher shorts
and wearing whatever sandals that you
are they just sandal other guerrilla
sandals man you got an uncle right now
that's on the grill and either the white
and blue New Balance or the white and
blue monarch monarchs or those guerrilla
Sanders men those are the only options
what is your creative process how do you
sit down and go I'm gonna make a video
how do you secure your own guy you freak
what you how do you start it sometimes I
think of that I had to end in mine like
I want to end the video and then I kind
of worked my way yeah so but most of
like the old head videos come from like
all my uncles that I saw growing up you
know I'm saying like I always had that
uncle who was like real tough on me
because my uncle had four sisters so he
was just like he was just like yo I
ain't raising no punks no punk come in
the house ten of them like what I got to
do ten push-ups like as soon as I seen
it was just like we played this game
called knuckles where you take a deck of
cards and no I slap your knuckles and
stuff like that like if you lost in a
game of tongue taught me how to play
tunt I would lose knuckles both give me
the notes let's go somewhere be able to
couch taught me how to like ride a bike
I rode a bike because I was scared of
him like I'm trying to get away from him
like detected we're gonna take the
training wheels off today like man it
just started yesterday right God J I
literally just got the hanger like
walking and stuff like that we're like
come on Mary time three come on man like
he ain't play around man
you think he was in like the military or
something like that looking back though
appreciate it yeah man you know yeah
that's that's that's my family
you know what I'm saying like and I had
I had another uncle who was just just
there pitting me a cool man every time
you see him I mean just smoke cigarettes
cool just like everything about what
flopping up and down everything he do
when you do cool uncle video spraying a
mist of Cologne and just walking into it
just like everything every taught hey
what's up cool breeze everything
everything copacetic with the family all
right now be easy everything he did was
just cool when did you stop being
nervous to put yourself out there
was it the Kevin Hart thing because
there's a thing with creators where we
know what we're doing is good yeah but
you need to push through that point
we're like I hope I don't get rejected
by everybody or did you never have that
no I never like really people talk to me
about that all the time you know fear
dude I've played in front of millions of
people breath so like I'm kind of I
guess I'm kind of like used to that I'm
saying yeah but like going I was the
only child like I don't have any
brothers and sisters or whatever so I
used to always want to entertain people
today I always want to come back over to
my house so I would do little slapstick
stuff like I'll fall down the stairs I
would like just trip and just fall
somewhere so just so people kind of
laugh what he's gonna do next
yes going for anything house again he
gonna do something crazy so and then you
know I started I've been in this same
size a high since I was like 12 so
everybody thought I was gonna be like 6
6 6 7 or what
like nope I grew horizontally just not
vertically you know say so I've always
been a big dude you know me and then you
know I said I just played Nintendo when
I was just laying the joysticks I used
to throw the chairs and stuff down when
I used to lose and stuff like that my
mom would be like you got to find a way
to channel this energy so she's like you
gonna play football so she just dropped
me off at Martin Luther King high school
in Detroit said go introduce yourself to
that coach Coach Reynolds go up there I
turn around we started you know and he
goes you're in well thanks know at this
time I was I had passed the test
yeah it's three top schools in Detroit
cast King Renaissance I passed the test
to go to the king my mom was like cool
take you up there right now I had on
jean shorts like some flip-flops in like
a tank top 20 ready she was ready oh
really
I wasn't ready but you know he said go
you know warm up take a lap do this
whatever blah blah we do that we all get
together we do push-ups we do jumping
jacks like oh yeah I'm like damn like
this is what's hot on the street right
here I'm like oh you were digging it
yeah cuz I growing up I never really
want to play football cuz all my
cousin's my god man you'll get hurt man
you'll hurt your knee your hurt ankle
you do this whatever blah so we always
played basketball on my neighborhood
Detroit Pistons you know saying bad boy
with the bad boys you grew up with the
Fab five yeah man hitch you probably
like the perfect time in your teenage
years all about hooping in my
neighborhood yeah so when I was on JV
they told me to at football practice
they told me to line up at garb I looked
the coach dead in his eyes a shooting
guard or point guard that's amazing
coach was like you know our coach Pete
look at this dump Louie just dumped self
it look at how he's shooting guard a
point guard look at his dumb look at his
dummy what are you talking about so man
I had to but anyways I used so many
football players that were basketball
players yeah especially line you don't
allow that side-to-side agility and all
that stuff too but yeah man but anyway
football it's like a form of
entertainment so you know wanting to
entertain people to come up back over to
my house and then being thrust in the
football that being a former
entertainment I did that all the way
till I was aged what 31 or something
like that and then it's like dang now
what am I gonna do so I started creating
the videos and stuff like that and
that's been a form entertainment for me
so I'm back in my element
how many retired guys reach out to you
for advice a lot because they've you're
an advocate for a lot of them I'm sure
yeah they feel like you know they can
make that transition or whatever but
it's it's not easy man
like you go through a tough patch where
you just like do ain't no checks coming
in I'm making all these videos for free
yes and and people are telling me that
I'm [ __ ] killing it
I'm stagnant like I get you know 5,000
followers and you know three months time
I get 5,000 100 followers it's like man
why do I keep making these videos man
and it ain't really paying off yeah I
think it's funny
other people think it's funny I don't
know if they telling me they think it's
funny cuz we homeboys and stuff like
that so it's it's a tough little grind
man but I'm a nose guard man that's what
we do is grind so you know I'm used to
that man but I think like it's like like
I was saying with the cream Biggums
thing like I didn't want to put it out
like I thought it was stupid but it's
the stuff that you think is stupid that
you don't spend the most time on is the
stuff that pop the stuff where you get
like all of these lights yeah
you get the great mic setup you got the
nice little cameras on my record this
and 4k at 60 frames per second or
whatever watch when I do it I'm gonna
put that in slow-mo i'ma send it over
here to get edited and then i'ma put
this I'm putting like a strobe light in
or whatever then I'm gonna do
after-effects whatever that's and stuff
they get like 10,000 views I say to this
view all the time I was talking to
someone they were planning to do a prank
and I said shoot the whole prank on
cellphones and they said why we have
cameras I said because people want
user-generated content it's real it's
natural all of your stuff feels like
it's someone at the
barbecue right recording it for Balaji
when did it go from 5100 to it like I'm
like when when did you start getting
that that I think it's like like the
word-of-mouth deal where it's like you
got somebody who's who has a lot of
followers who post your stuff or it's
like a site that has a lot of followers
yeah like you know bleacher report would
like post something then all of a sudden
I get 10,000 followers something like
that then somebody else gets a hold of
it and then I get 10,000 from there and
then somebody else sees it and it's kind
of like a domino effect who was the
first brand that came to you and said we
want to work with you the I mean other
than ABARES yeah you're doing stuff with
the Bears you're doing a baking show
which i think is amazing yeah man it's
not off to the great American bacon show
dude um but you're like an actual like I
know you did stuff with Old Spice yeah a
brand yeah um cuz that's gotta be a cool
phone call to get yeah I did well I have
I did some things with whistle sports
sure and through whistle sports they
hooked me up with like a McDonald's with
Sprint with Old Spice and things like
that man so that's so uh it was through
whistle sports that I started working
with brands whatever but I think I also
did something with gosh it's been a
journey man it's been a lot man yeah
I've worked with a lot of but I work
with uh with Kellogg's did a lot of
things work a lot I did a basketball
celebrity basketball at the with
Kellogg's I was on Team cheez-its and I
saw this you were dancing off with Shaq
yeah and then your video right now if
you air balling threes every time
there's an NBA player that doesn't play
well what is that like when every time
something happens in the NBA your
whether it's a ha ha or it's that video
like what's it like to see it explode
again it's gonna be because it's like
people put their own spin on it whatever
and it's like it's organic so for
instance I'll put the video out myself
and it'd probably get like 10,000 views
20,000 views or something like that
but just like Mike likes to eat Oreos
like aunt Mike likes to eat Oreos on
Twitter he puts it out and it gets 10
million views you don't say humbly puts
like a caption over it like me shooting
my shot in the dm's yes and it's just
like it goes crazy man yeah that's why
that's why the internet is what it is I
think the cool thing is as a commentary
to you so many people love to post your
[ __ ] because they know that you're a
good [ __ ]
and I think that they see that it comes
from a good place every character that
you do the reason I think it resonates
with people is it's a character that
they know is coming from a real place
and it's not a mockery it's more of like
a leaning into why it's funny
yeah I mean I think all my stuff too you
know I got four kids man so like all my
stuff is like office friendly so nobody
is really like right scared to click on
it at work
yeah scared to click on it around at
kids and stuff like that man so you know
it's a safe place man and I try to take
care of everybody man I need to get you
to the airport because you got to get
the [ __ ] out of here but I think I want
the 33 percent the homies to fully
support spice in everything because I
think what he's doing is organic and it
is natural to anyone out there that is
trying to do their own media thing that
is trying to create their own content
what would be your your words of wisdom
as someone that's in that grind right
now I would say keep putting content out
no matter how stupid you think it is no
matter how great you think it is just
constantly keep pushing it out and and
stand behind your work you know what I
mean like that's how you create your
brand like if you believe in yourself
and you had that confidence in yourself
then I think all of your videos or all
your media all of your content is gonna
go far yeah
saying like think about jay-z I he he
was just talking on hot 97 where he was
talking about his uncle was putting his
fears on him
you know because he could have made that
record yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying
but jay-z he believed in himself and not
as man as a billionaire
it was often dependent he did
Rockefeller and then it turned into yeah
rock nation and it's all independently
only got in sports agency yeah
art clothing line like I said you're not
gonna invest in me I'm gonna do it to
myself and all my masters it's a good
lesson for everybody
dude now he is the best now he is the
master spice
I appreciate you yes big-time a man
again the great American bank you so
won't let me sleep
that's one what else should they watch
watch me on Instagram that's five
thousands what about the Bears watch the
Bears the Bears so inside the Bears
tidal bears complex inside the beards
what about cream Begum's IG cream
becomes creamy Biggums B IgG UMS check
out all of them
he's now invited to the 33% family spice
you gotta work on you do you have an old
school rap character too I can make out
what you want me to freestyle if you
want freestyling to the beat hey get
Nike summer feet lay where my narcs
hey like all right like I was jay-z huh
you know you can't play me up straight
from the Det they called me on the cell
III 1/3 the baby ever you co when I be
in boss mode
they say that boy code and I say I know
man coming through the snow it don't
matter why can a cootie sweater no
matter the weather is about to be June
then it's gonna be July coming down oh
to be one-off we gotta catch a flight
[Music]